mais dazhou l'album gentleman 2.0 et
j'ai un truc à te donner encore à chaque
fois que tu viens
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
voilà merci pas de crêpes aujourd'hui
c'est quoi double disque de platine est
remarquable aujourd'hui tu veux des
crêpes non attends moi j'étais de choses
j'ai quelque chose à dire pas fait parce
que tu penses qu'il ya que des employés
qui sont ici en fait il était bon ça
c'est ma maison
non non non je parle des techniciens
ouais tu as payé que j'ai dû payer plus
cher pour leurs te ramener ça s'il vous
plaît ramenez lui signe quoi
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
j'étais
[Applaudissements]
c'est magnifique c'est que je vais faire
une salle en fait je sais faire une
salle avec des disques odeurs que j'ai
pas eu des disques platine et ses fans
et d'ajouter qui m'a fait un cadeau de
ouf
non mais ne t'inquiète pas c'est dommage
merci frère on s'étonne un pur et ligne
alors attends j'ai les clés de ma
bagnole on peut disque de platine
d'ailleurs ta mère était très très fier
double disque de platine ce qu'on l'a vu
danser sur instagram regarde les très
grandes idoles
j'ai pas un énorme bisou et va être
contente la map les juste avant que je
monte sur scène et à chaque fois on lui
fait des bisous à chaque fois que tu
veux si c'est vrai et était le frère de
maître gims c'est ça voilà qu'on aura
c'est maître gims et mon frère là bas
ils arrivent au départ tout le monde
disait que ses deux frères de maitre
gims maintenant ce que m rim se dit en
me dit partout que suis ton frère or
l'usiné sauber de dazhou toussaint ouais
on les dit ouais c'est vraiment arrangé
un couac dazhou toute idylle en tournée
dans toute la france c'est déjà complet
quasiment partout sous le lit il sera
notamment à l'olympia le 11 mai et au
zénith de paris le 28
badji djoman 2.0 mais pas aidé at il
tout à l'heure quand on revient le but
tu me fais règne si tu veux